my mother and father I was very
privileged to have really wonderful
parents but also when I was a young
woman in Belfast I remember admiring the
life of Dorothy Day night Dorothy Day
lived in America a long way away from me
and and Dorothy's life was committed to
working against war and militarism and
she set up homes for the poor and lived
with the poor and I just always thought
she was such a tremendous woman and I
was very privileged after I won the
Nobel Prize I went to downtown New York
to one of the Catholic workers where
Dorothy was living and I carried my
noble metal and especially to shorter
and one of my friends says oh they'll be
carrying that around here this you could
get robbed her and don't be kinder than
here but I tried it into Dorothy Day too
short to her because as a young woman
she had inspired me and her message was
no to militarism and war and to spending
the money and taking care of the poor
and had America left listen to that
message way back then there wouldn't be
so much militarism more in poverty so
she inspired me